having a debate party be sure to include
these great candidate themed cocktails
the Donald Trump start by taking someone
else's glass even if they're using it
you're going to use it better then add
anything domestic imported spirits are
not the best they bring hangovers
blackouts crime some I assume are good
drinks but we want American then build a
wall around it top it off with a dead
squirrel and insult the next woman you
see the ben Carson this is an absinthe
drink it messes with your head and is
surprisingly strong given the lack of
substance before long you'll be that guy
at the party saying weird things about
the Holocaust and evolution and whatever
else comes to mind it starts oh look at
that the Trump cocktail is a hat now
okay that's kind of funny I guess what
was I saying the Jeb Bush start with a
glass of whatever alcohol made you
really sick the last time you drank it
then water it down add a common apple
core and oh yeah the Trump cocktail
again yeah it has it's got little flag
umbrellas the rand paul this is a new
twist on an older more popular cocktail
pay close attention as the ingredients
have recently changed the okay can we
stop looking at the Trump cocktail I
know it's flashy and it's different but
really there are a lot of other drinks
here and seriously you are just
encouraging bad behavior at this point
okay forget it this is why no one likes
your parties America